described you before a third of the
people we pass the sheet they gave it
back to us a third of the people we
passed it they shredded it they came to
us and said mr. experimenter I solved X
problems give me X dollars a third of
the people when they finish reading the
piece of paper they came to us and said
mr. experimenter I solved X problems
give me X tokens we did not pay them
with dollars we pay them with something
else and then they took this something
else they walked 12 feet to the side and
exchanged it for dollars think about the
following intuition how bad would you
feel about taking a pencil from work
home compared to how bad would you feel
about taking ten cents from a petty cash
box these things feel very differently
with being a step removed from cash for
a few seconds by being paid by token
make a difference our subjects double
their cheating I'll tell you what I
think about this in the stock market in
a minute but this did not solve the big
problem I had with anyone yet because in
n1 is also a social element people see
each other behaving in fact every day
when we open the news we see examples of
people cheating what does this causes us
so we did another experiment we got the
big group of students to be in the
experiment and we prepaid them so
everybody got an envelope with all the
money for the experiment and we told
them at the end we asked them to pay us
back the money they didn't make okay the
same thing happens when we give people
the opportunity to cheat they cheat that
you just buy a little bit all the same
but in this experiment we also
higher than acting students this acting
student stood up after 30 seconds and
said I solved everything what do I do
now and the experiment is that if you
finished everything go home that's it
the task is finished so now we had a
student an acting student that was a
part of the group nobody knew there was
though it was an actor and they clearly
cheated in a very very serious way what
would happen to the other people in the
group will they cheat more or will they
cheat less here is what happens it turns
out it depends on what kind of
sweatshirts they are wearing here is the
thing we ran this at a Carnegie Mellon
in Pittsburgh and the Carnegie meets
book that two big universities Carnegie
Mellon University of Pittsburgh all of
the subjects sitting in the experiment
were Carnegie Mellon students when the
actor was getting up was the Carnegie
Mellon student pretty it was actually a
con email student but he was a part of
their group cheating went up but when he
actually had the University of
Pittsburgh sweatshirt cheating went down
now this is important because remember
when the moment the student stood up it
made it clear to everybody that they
could get away with cheating because the
experimenter said you finished
everything go home and they worked with
the money so it wasn't so much about the
probability of being caught again it was
about the norms for cheating somebody
from our in-group cheats and we see them
cheating we feel it's more appropriate
as a group to behave this way but if
it's somebody from another group these
terrible people I mean not terrible in
this but somebody we don't want to
associate ourselves with from another
university another group office and
people awareness of honesty goes up a
little bit like the Ten Commandment
experiment and people cheat even even
less so what what have we learned from
this about cheating we've learned that a
lot of people can cheat they cheat just
by a little bit when we remind people
about their morality they cheat less
when we get bigger distance from
cheating from the object of money for
example people cheat more
and when we see things of cheating
around us particularly it's a part of
our in-group cheating goes up now if we
think about this in terms of the stock
market think about what happens what
happens in a situation when you create
something where you pay people a lot of
money to see reality in a slightly
distorted way would they not be able to
see it this way of course they would
what happens when you do other things
like you remove things for money
you call them stock of stock option
derivatives mortgage-backed securities
could it be that with those more distant
things it's not a token for one second
it's something that these many steps
removed for money for much longer time
could it be but people would cheat even
more and what happened to the social
environment when people see other people
behave around them I think all of those
forces worked in a very bad way in the
stock market
more generally I want to tell you
something about behavior economics we
have many intuitions
in our life and the point is that many
of these intuitions are wrong the
question is are we going to test those
intuitions we can think about how we're
going to test this intuition in our
private life in our business life and
most particularly when it goes to policy
when we think about things like No Child
Left Behind when you create new stock
markets when you create other policies
taxation health care and so on and the
difficulty of testing on intuition was
was the big lesson I learned when I went
back to the nurses to talk to them so I
went back to talk to them and tell them
what I found out about removing bandages
and I learned two interesting things one
was that my favorite nurse Ettie
told me that I did not take her pain
into consideration she said of course
you know it was very painful for you but
think about me as a nurse taking
removing the bandages of somebody I
liked and had to do it repeatedly over a
long period of time creating so much
torture was not something that was good
for me too and she said maybe part of
the reason what it was it was difficult
for her it was actually more interesting
than that because she said I did not
think that your intuition was right I
thought my intuition was correct so if
you think about all of your intuition
think about it's very hard to believe
that your intuition is
wrong and she said given the fact that I
thought my intuition was right she
thought her intuition was right it was
very difficult for her to accept doing a
difficult experiment to try and check
whether she was wrong but the fact this
is the situation we're all brawling all
the time we have very strong intuitions
about all kinds of things our own
ability how the economy work how we
should pay schoolteachers but unless we
start testing those intuitions we're not
going to do better and just think about
how better my life would have been if
these nurses would have been willing to
check their intuition and how everything
would have been better we would just
start doing more systematic
experimentation of our intuitions thank
you very much
you